well my friends it is happening again a
lawyer for former vice president Mike
Pence recently discovered a dozen
classified documents at Mike Pence's
Indiana home these documents have now
been turned over to the FBI for review
now at this early stage in this new
investigation related to classified
documents it's not completely clear what
documents were found at Mike Pence's
house their level of sensitivity or
other details but let's remember that
multiple times former vice president
Mike Penn stated there are no classified
documents in my possession there are no
classified documents at my house now
let's think about this just for a moment
because this is becoming a much bigger
story than any particular classified
document although we will get to the
aspect of the story that relates to
classification that's a separate story
it's a relevant one but it's a separate
story think for a moment the same
Republicans who were furiously
apoplectically up in arms about the
supposed mishandling of classified
documents at Joe Biden's private office
and residence are now conveniently
silent about the discovery of classified
documents at the home of another one of
their own because remember the same
thing happened with Donald Trump with
hundreds of documents which he tried to
keep and wanted at his house
orders of magnitude difference between
these stories but you one could argue
you put the Trump's situation aside that
the Biden and Pence situations are much
more analogous or similar I want to
remind you of some things that former
vice president Mike Pence previously
said here is an interview that Mike
Pence gave to ABC News back in November
and this exact topic came up you take
any classified documents with you from
the White House
uh I I did not no
do you see any reason for anyone to take
classified documents with them leaving
the White House
well there'd be no reason to have
classified documents particularly if
they were in an unprotected area
right now is his answer technically
correct in that someone else took them
assistance took them whatever you know
we we start to get into this more
semantic discussion of what does it
really mean to take what does it really
mean to have what does it really mean to
relocate a document but of course the
spirit of this conversation
is that there are no such documents at
his house here's another uh example of
Mike Pence this was from uh earlier this
month in fact take a listen to this one
our staff reviewed all of the materials
in our office and wow in our residence
to ensure oh that there were no
classified
materials that that left the White House
or remained in our possession and I I
remain confident that that was done in a
thorough and careful way I guess it
wasn't right I guess I guess he was
wrong about that as well and has
completely lost control of what's going
on in his home I mean there were fun
house mirrors and you couldn't tell that
the documents were classified who the
hell knows but obviously not true let's
look at one more instance of this here
is Mike Pence in a previous interview
saying he doesn't want to diminish the
importance of protecting classified
documents and that everything was very
buttoned up every eye was crossed and T
dotted I know I know it's a it's a
Hannity thing um here is Mike Patrick
ever want to diminish uh the importance
of protecting classified documents in
the nation's secret there was a very
formal process during my time it was
super formal everybody wore tuxedos
while they did it at the White House to
see to that yeah no it all have oh by
the way he had documents at his house
despite claiming multiple times that he
didn't so my biggest ass my biggest
issue with this story is the astounding
hypocrisy that is that has come to light
and has become I mean unabashedly they
don't even blush when they present their
double standards and it goes to show
that the Republican party will play
politics with National Security
if we believe that they consider this
issue of classified documents to be a
matter of National Security they claim
it is at least when it's Joe Biden if we
believe that
and yet they still use these situations
to attack the opposing party but never
themselves
it means they are turning a blind eye to
the very national security issue that
they claim these National these uh
classified document situations represent
which means there is nothing they will
not play politics with and that's
absolutely the case now there's another
issue okay I read online people saying
well you at this point you should really
check every former president's house and
office and every former vice president's
house and office apparently because of
what's going on
I propose to you
that this is not limited to presidents
and vice presidents it would be a shock
to me if they were to search the offices
and Residences of cabinet members for
example
um maybe not Secretary of the Interior
but certainly like Secretary of State as
an example I would be shocked if there
weren't some classified documents at the
homes of others as well Democrats
Republicans notice I'm not mentioning
partisan politics here is it ridiculous
or is it to be expected I don't know you
know the truth is that elected officials
review thousands or tens of thousands of
files when they're in office things get
moved around things could get misfiled
misclassified misplaced whatever it's
not a defense by the way I believe every
one of these cases should be
investigated and I'll get to that in a
moment but when you are dealing with
this volume of documents and you're
dealing with human beings after all it's
not a huge shock what it shouldn't be is
a partisan issue if it is determined
that files have been found
and it genuinely seems that it was an
accident in oversight whatever they
should be returned immediately law
enforcement should look into it and then
we have to move on and go beyond that
now as I said before the doj should
treat every one of these situations the
same in that they should investigate all
of them if and when the investigation
reveals that the facts of each situation
is different then you start dealing with
the situations differently and so if you
look at the Pence and Biden situations
which I do believe are quite similar and
you find this was not intentional these
documents were founded immediately
turned over etc etc and then you look at
the Trump situation and you're talking
about hundreds not a dozen documents
you're talking about people on video
moving them or moving these documents
around when Trump has already been asked
to return them you look at Trump using
lawyers to try not to return them and
then the lawyers lie and say we've
turned over everything we have have but
then it turns out they didn't that is a
different set of facts and so that would
change the scope and nature of the
investigation now Mitch McConnell was
asked about this and he sort of played
Coy take a look at what he said
records showing at the price uh Joe
Biden's home and now we're running
around what happened Mike Pence and what
specifically should Congress do to
prevents
well if recorder has a justice
department handles it I think they ought
to treat everybody the same who has
misplaced
uh classified documents now that is an
interesting statement because it does
appear that Joe Biden misplaced
documents
from what we know
at this point it seems as though Mike
Pence misplaced documents but Trump
stole documents Trump gathered up had
gathered up hundreds of documents and
had him sent to his house that's very
different than a dozen documents were
left over and they were found then
immediately returned so in a sense you
know the spirit of what Mitch McConnell
is saying sure yeah I mean treat all
these things the same and that they
should all be investigated but misplaced
is a mischaracterization of much of what
we believe took place here now there I
want to bring up a separate but valid
issue is there over classification of
documents in the United States you know
I'm not going to be able to answer this
question for you in order to really
answer this question accurately one
needs to have access to documents I
simply don't have access to and one
needs to have uh insight into the exact
process for classification that I
certainly don't have but we've talked
about over criminalization in society
as a problem and separately there are
people who have access to this apparatus
of classification who say that in the
United States we habitually over
classify documents and that arguably
some of these documents could be the
Biden documents the Pence documents the
Trump documents whatever some of these
documents maybe really shouldn't even
have been classified in the first place
a difficult question for me or many of
you in the audience to answer but
certainly a valid question that Canon
should be asked